ce bébé ne se doute pas qu'il est avec
beaucoup d'autres l'une des causes du
surmenage des sages-femmes
1965 et déjà la télévision française
parle du surmenage des sages femmes
c'est vrai qu'il ya actuellement une
enquête ouverte concernant le surmenage
des sages-femmes qu'en pensez vous eh
bien je trouve que notre travail est
quand même un travail assez dur parce
que c'est un travail très irrégulier un
travail d'urgence et qu'on allait moment
très chargée le manque de personnel est
aussi pointée du doigt est-ce qu'il ya
suffisamment de sages femmes en france
je crois qu'il n'y en a pas beaucoup je
crois qu'il sort à peu près 250 sages
femmes par an en france et que ça
représente peu de chose manque de
personnel et salaires trop bas comme ici
en 1972 seul votre métier comme travail
pour gagner de l'argent en communication
le métier passion la vocation a ses
limites surtout quand les compétences
s'élargissent les sages femmes sont
présentes avant pendant et après
l'accouchement tout comme les médecins
elle ont le droit de prescrire des
médicaments pourtant elles ont toujours
le statut de personnel médical à
responsabilité limitée
alors les grèves se répète comme ici en
1989 le quotidien des sages femmes
celles écoute permanente des autres
aujourd'hui soutenus par des mamans
solidaire elle souhaite qu'on prenne le
temps de les écouter l
les années passent et les revendications
sont les mêmes une meilleure
reconnaissance du métier et plus
d'effectifs un constat fait dans cette
maternité de montreuil en seine saint
denis en 2003 cette pénurie de personnel
c'est un vrai casse-tête aussi pour
christine piccola chef de service pour
s'en sortir
tout le monde fait des heures sup malgré
tout il a fallu rogner sur certaines
prestations qu'on travaille maintenant
dans des conditions qui sont plus en
plus difficile qu'ils deviennent même
dangereuse parfois en 2014
jour la même colère et après plus de
quatre mois de conflit
la ministre de la santé annonce une
mesure de compromis avec un statut
médical spécifique pour les sages femmes
mais pas l'obtention du statut de
praticien hospitalier
insuffisant ça correspond à rien et
sages femmes après quatre mois et demi
grève responsable sans incidence rien on
a fait d'être allé travailler on avait
nos assignation on a fait tout comme il
fallait ça va pas eh ben on va durcir et
puis on va montrer au gouvernement que
peut-être il va falloir avoir peur aussi
des sages-femmes et arrêter d'avoir peur
des médecins ou des centrales
aujourd'hui c'est toujours pour ce
statut de praticien hospitalier synonyme
de revalorisation salariale que les
sages femmes sont en grève une
augmentation d'ailleurs préconisée par
l'inspection générale des affaires
sociales à hauteur de 500 à 600 euros
par mois elles nous ont fait naître
est-ce que le gouvernement va les
reconnaître
[Musique]